Best Buy is the best boom big-box retail
store that sells consumer electronics in
America recently they have had some
trouble as Amazon has started to grow
however they have been able to
successfully combat that but did you
know about Best Buy's miserable failure
in China
make sure stick around till the end to
find out welcome to hurry saw bees so
when Best Buy was thinking about going
into China it seemed like a really good
idea they had the biggest market after
all as they have the biggest population
in the world on top of this the middle
class was going very rapidly and the
cherry on top was that most electronics
manufacturing already took place in
China and such proximity would really
help out as well also Best Buy didn't
just randomly enter the market they
actually studied for three years but
clearly that wasn't enough when they
entered they bought a majority stake in
a local retailer named Jing suit
five-star appliance in 2006 from there
they started their operations and bred
in nine of those stores as Best Buy
stores which mimic American stores
everything from a layout or organization
to sales tactics were identical to
American Best Buy stores they made sure
to hire knowledgeable staff members who
could actually guide customers and give
recommendations and tell them what to
look out for and they've sold staple
American parts including home
entertainment systems laptops and
computers but unfortunately the influx
of customers they were hoping for never
materialized and within five years they
were struggling severely they had a
measly 1.8 percent market share and
closed all of their brand new stores in
2011 but they continued five-star of
plans which they had completely bought
out in 2008 as they hope that this would
propel growth then CEO Brian done really
wanted to focus on the mobile sections
of these doors but soon enough lifestyle
also failed in China and Best Buy mostly
withdrew from the country so what
happened to Best Buy and why did it fail
in China for starters China has a lot of
counterfeits and this
really hurt Best Buy's business China
has extensive manufacturing
infrastructure and this makes it easy
for competitors to ripoff best buy
products and sell them for a cheaper
price but Best Buy didn't just have to
do counterfeits they also had to deal
with piracy
is also very common in China and local
shops usually install pirated software
onto their laptops and computers this
again allowed them to offer their parts
for a cheaper price which is more
appealing to consumers Best Buy was also
undercutting prices by local stores for
other reasons as well they would give
their employees much less salaries and
benefits and they didn't have to pay as
much for rent and electricity as there
are much smaller than Best Buy stores
also Best Buy would offer store
warranties that the Chinese people
really did not like they were really
used to manufacturer warranties and I
wanted those this is because the main
difference between manufacturer warranty
against or warranties is that you had to
pay for store warranties this again in
flair their product crisis and made it
really tough for them to compete with
local competition and the thing was best
fair parties were simply too expensive
for the average person and I said before
Best Buy did do research and what they
found was the average middle-class
person was willing to pay a premium if
it was from a well-known brand and Apple
is the perfect example of this as her
biggest market actually China not the
United States
the Shanghai Apple store sells more
iPhones per square foot than any other
Apple store in the entire world
not to mention that iPhones cost 30%
more in China than in the United States
so it's clear that Chinese people are
about to pay a price premium but the
thing with the iPhone is premium pricing
is that you can't get the iPhone
anywhere else there are countries but
those are significantly worse but Best
Buy Stoney's home entertainment systems
and Samsung TVs could be found in other
places for cheaper prices and as for the
piracy thing most people in town don't
care if their laptops come with the
pirated version of Windows or Microsoft
Office because it still runs just the
same with iPhone counterfeits you can't
get the same performance and quality but
here it's just a moral issue and the
thing was Best Buy didn't provide an
adequate explanation
as to why they were charging premium
prices their target audience the middle
class didn't understand why best buys
products were more expensive and this
led them to flock to cheaper stores also
Best Buy stores are way too large best
buy clearly did not do their research as
this was not even close to the normal
size of local retailers they opened good
old big-box stores just like in America
and state that this would help sales but
this simply inflate expenses which is
reflected in the pricing and these large
stores were also located very far away
from houses China does not want the
highest card ops rates but their traffic
is terrible this along with the lack of
parking made most consumers preferred
local stores are closer to home there
was also a government ban on giving off
free shopping bags and so consumers at
the buy shopping bags each time this
week consumers go shopping more often
and buy less items each time they can
carry at home without using bags and of
course that also made them prefer closer
neighborhood stores instead what they
should have been doing is localizing
stores matching the local retail format
that would have created a much more even
playing field and giving Best Buy an
actual chance then oh the president of
Asian Best Buy stores says that the
retail has moved in Asia were stupid and
arrogant they replicated Us store models
which was a bad decision they were
essentially trying to change the
industry instead of working on the pace
of the normal Chinese consumer and this
would really hurt them their stores were
not positioned well and dis limited
their geographic reach they did have a
hundred and eighty four five-star stores
but a majority of these stores are
placed in the Eastern Province of
Jiangsu this heavily limited the reach
and was evident in retailer standings in
five-star was the 18th largest retailer
in China while this may sound good most
of their competitors were ahead of them
their competitors stores were spread
across China and there were aggressively
opening new locations and that brings me
to the point that Best Buy had to deal
with intense competition from local
Giants it wasn't just a local stores
were under
in Best Buy's prices but there is huge
local Giants that you exactly what the
consumers wanted Romans tuning posed
great competition to retail locations of
Best Buy and Jada comment Teemo created
huge ecommerce competition as well and
to make it all worse at this point the
Chinese economy growth was actually
slowing down and a combination of all of
these issues along with the fact that
best guys incurring massive losses even
in America made it so if the most
logical decision was to sell all of
their Chinese stores and focused on
North American market and this was to
end up Best Buy's adventures in China
and they exited a market in 2014 best
buy in depth under 180 for fact our
stores to a domestic real estate firm
called Zhejiang Jade Ewen Gruber's but
the financial terms to the deal were not
disclosed and just a year before this
they also exist the European market due
to similar issues after slogging there
for five years as well
Best Buy stores in Europe were also to
American and clearly Best Buy didn't
understand the European market either
but distant means they completely exited
an international market altogether they
still continued at first in Canada and
Mexico under the leadership of Coober
Jolie who really focused on North
American market and even in China they
continued to invest in private label
operations but that counts for less than
5% of their yearly revenue so it's not
that crucial and with that Best Buy was
back to really focusing on North
American market once again Best Buy is a
classic example of a huge American storm
failing internationally there are other
huge stores who have had similar
experiences like Target in Canada
Starbucks in Australia Walmart in
Germany and Home Depot and again China
the main problems common to pretty much
all of these downfalls was not adapting
and localizing to local cultures they
were trying to force all work America on
to these foreign markets and this
resulted in huge losses for all of these
companies but it was a good rule for
Best Buy to actually exit China
this will allowed them to focus on the
North American business which was also
dying and that was essential and
avoiding bankruptcy
and putting Best Buy back on the right
track but that's all I have for you guys
have a white best buy filled in China
major comment down below what company
you would like me to cover next also if
you guys like to get me to drop a like
and consider subscribing if you like see
more videos just like this one but till
then harden also guys on actual
[Music]
[Applause]